television has actually been a bigger
bloodbath than even the political
landscape lately the up front we're this
week and this is where the network's
tell you what's coming in the upcoming
season in this case the fall and that
usually comes with the big axe where
they chop away at all the crap that
nobody's watching and we got an
incredible set of charts here to show
you how many things were cancelled here
we go so this is ABC they got rid of 666
Park Avenue body approved don't trust
the B in apartment 23 happy endings how
to live with your parents for the rest
of your life last resort Malibu Country
private practice red widow zero hour NBC
30 Rock's 1600 Penn animal practice
deception do no harm go on guys with
kids the new normal the office ready for
love rock center with brian williams
smash up all night and whitney CBS CSI
to your golden boy the job made in
Jersey partners rules of engagement and
vegas and the CW i didn't even know they
were still on 90210 cult Emily Owens
m.d. gossip girl now just real quick
yeah you watch all this that's all I
watch oh wait Fox wait now i forgot
about fox i watch them fox has basically
the least of the big boys because
they're the olympians ben and kate cops
which is moving to spike fringe the mob
doctor wait do they have new episodes
tops it's good yeah cops is really
people thought it got cancelled like two
months ago but now it's going over to
somebody my schedule July United 95 like
a surprise cops to know about cops oh
wait too weird we like doughnuts too
yeah I love watching cops when I was a
kid babo is bad boys their job do now 30
rock Doug wasn't canceled they don't
have planned end yes so a few of those
shows good point i want to mention they
were the office also went out via
natural a little late but it went that's
has been long as your slaves for a show
ever this ending of the office i feel
like it's been three months everybody
share isn't on that she's still doing
her farewell tour that she started in
1999 it's like a jewish to buy all right
let's go to the car
already nonno's do you remember to send
me the recipe for the ground come on we
have to go she won't leave she won't
leave and just like the office yeah so
there are okay so there's a lot of
things i wanna talk about here because a
lot of that was just crap that no one's
ever watched and no one ever will watch
but some of it then was with some of the
good stuff what do you we are so what do
you think is the is really going on here
is this just the changing attitudes of
people in television is it because we're
all getting stuff from netflix now and
we're all watching on demand and all
that stuff or are they just making crap
are they just crap it's just crap crap
yeah well i think it's a combination of
things a lot of networks are now
focusing on reality TV because it's
super cheap to produce and the profit is
massive people love to watch train
wrecks right and i think that netflix
has a lot to do with it too um I just
recently canceled my cable because I
love watching old shows on Netflix yeah
right now I'm into breaking bad and I
know that originally it was on TV about
20 minutes never watched a single I was
watching an old show the other day it's
called I Love Lucy yeah did you ever get
those beds together they no no not till
10 years after they went on yeah that's
like 20 tell the other day we scoped
uncle Miltie and yeah I was the the
first show that was ever NTV 1952 I know
popcorn when it came out by the way I
address I jackée Harry on the show last
week and she saw Uncle milkies penis she
did yeah he showed it to her once oh
pretty good do you know he was very
famous for being well endowed oh really
yes they had a huge contest once at the
Friars Club and someone said I'm gonna
challenge you and he said you take it
out and so if he said well you go first
and so the Challenger unzipped his fly
and he showed his penis and then he said
okay my uncle Miltie Milton Berle go
ahead and Milton Berle unzipped his fly
and he said that's not so big he said it
only took out enough to beat you Wow
yeah it's a fine line between the Friars
Club and a gay bar right there alright
so far as better drinks yeah
but speaking again one thing I couldn't
help but notice here is that a bunch of
gay programs disappeared the new normal
partner smash go on they all had gay
characters or gay story lines we get
like a ton of gay in the media now but
is it does is there something about it
that doesn't work for some reason in a
TV show is there something like we're
trying to push this thing on what the
network's think gay gay guys are like
dogs if they put a dog on TV again you
don't get give it a gay guy on TV the
gang goes gonna run up to the Vigo I
think yes yeah you know dogs wha I mean
you know it's silly and really they put
all these gay characters in but that's
not what gay men watch gay men are
watching housewives rip the crap out of
each other on Bravo that's what they
want to see and they're not watching gay
care they go that guy's a briefcase is
going to our great niceties and I do
that hey look at that crazy woman with
too much makeup on that's what they're
watching for the cooking channel you
should be working for Andy Cohen yeah
I'd see it I could see it um yeah Andy
Cohen would run for me I think I mean
because Bravo is you know it's very um
it's very specific right they don't have
a comedian sensibility Kathy Griffin's
on every 15 minutes I cancelled now
wasn't on my list wasn't sure it's like
she's still just a special every other
week yeah yeah she is on Bravo quite a
bit I hated the theme song to her show
though but what's uh no no no no no oh
she get it I don't know there's gonna be
a lot of comments about that ok I love
her I hated the theme song because they
played it over and over again throughout
the entire show yeah yeah i was
listening to an oldie the other day yeah
you like it why don't you put a ring on
it she's 11 years old 2010 not easy when
you drink that was not only something
else all right so my only other question
on this we're all over the place now we
should be why how does it that they make
this crap because we are all those
things I saw the commercials for all
them and it's just you know it's crap
each time you watch it you know it's
crap and then they canceled it and then
they rehire
same people soon after al out the same
writers the same key grips and they're
messing the whole thing I fail upwards
in television yeah but I know it's also
interesting ways usually there'll be one
network that comes up with a really
great show idea so like American Idol is
an example right and then you'll have
like a billion other show to try to copy
that rival and they don't work because
people already have American Idol i got
a boy solution yeah exactly your sis why
do people fail up in this crazy cause
it's very strange but it's so expensive
this business that you can walk in with
the most magnificent idea in the world
if you're an untried entity they will
not give it to you they would rather
hire someone who knows how to fail then
an untested person who may succeed it's
just too expensive yeah did you this is
total sidebar but in all your days I
stand up and especially in the boom of
the 80s when everybody was getting a
sitcom left and right did you see guys
that you to make a phone call yes haha i
vote for TV a lot yeah in film I when I
get tired of the road I write for TV
yeah but did you ever see guys that you
thought were really incredible that
didn't get the break or the show vs. the
guys that you thought were kind of
whatever that the yet I know I'm really
putting you on the spot here but nope
will shut the camera one you can think
of oh no no um I think most people had a
good shot I think the problem with the
great comics that God a chance was again
it's like it's the Mets New York Mets
mentality they signed the greatest first
baseman who ever lived and they make him
a right fielder and that's what happened
to these comics they didn't follow the
Cosby example which was you take a
comics act like a man with five children
and put it into a situation they would
take great comics like John Mendoza who
I love and and he was just the most down
trodden serious and they give my family
and say no no that wasn't the act they
would take them and read they changed
their position and that didn't interpret
into the show they needed to take the
persona they paid all that money for and
let that express itself in the city
and they didn't again the guys who know
how to fail know how to take you know
bronze their gold medal and that's what
they did they bought gold medals & Bruns
them Lenovo's is the official outfitter
of the Ruben report I want to put you in
this shirt go to bonobos com enter code
trr 20 for twenty percent off your first
purchase